man calls 9-1-1 after sister ends his
wash cycle
Richmond Heights Police I see exactly
I'm on his side yeah how helpless do you
feel that you feel like the only way
you can't do it yeah I'm gonna let the
authorities take care of this the man
had called because his sister had taken
his clothes out of the washing machine
without his permission she should be in
jail forever forever right I mean this
is like I don't believe in capital
punishment but I will for this story I
will allow it same consent is half the
has he never lived in an apartment
complex look no means no but I mean
we're talking about consent yeah this is
the story of stopping wet yeah oh it was
his third that's it that's still on her
side
darks and whites what's wrong with that
yes or just I mean you're at least doing
two three is not if it's towel or
betting day nothing